voici gad elmaleh
de là messieurs
eh bien
quels artistes en cas cette chanson
c'est une chanson sur laquelle on a
dansé le semeur tout à fait bien sûr
c'est tout à fait l'époque bien sûr
c'est herbie hancock gad
on
ça c'est le chacha des six sous c'est la
chanson du film que vous allez coécrit
gad elmaleh avec merzak allouache qui
est le réalisateur c'est ça tout à fait
voilà et avec chouchou dans le rôle
principal
voilà exactement elle était la ja je
vais pas y aller a dit me devais pas
croiser en coulisses
oui je le croisais en coulisses on a
parlé un peu et elle était un peu ému
parce que c'était la première fois
qu'elle faisait de l'année elle m'a dit
j'ai peur parce que tu sers 10 ans et
toujours on sait pas trop
ouais mais j'aime beaucoup je sue mois
elle nous attend tout à l'heure à
l'apocalypse à la cas à l'organe cesser
votre fer en fait qui vous a présenté à
un personnage de travestis maghrébins à
pigalle un soir j'ai entendu la voix
simplement je me suis retourné j'ai vu
une espèce de créature hommes/femmes
miami 1 ni molette lâche un fait prouvé
chevalier va y arriver un truc très
important le bar mitzvah du petit
azoulay oui exactement
voilà j'ai un petit sketch mais c'est
normal vous étiez invité vous n'y avez
mal et on déjà vu l'émission tout le
temps paraît tout il n'est pas de souci
et donc c c'est un personnage qui m'a
troublé parce que c'est un mélange de
trucs de d'accent
d'accent que je connaissais bien un
accent arabe avec un côté un peu
efféminé
il y avait déjà un autre choc de pas mal
de chose qui m'intéressait et ce sketch
est devenu un des phares de votre
spectacle
enfin je ne sais pas quand phare dans le
sens où c'est un clignotant de ma
carrière voilà alors qu avec le sa
manière